ecco il filo conduttore
un intervento sarà appunto quello sulla
negazione dei problemi delle periferie
ovvero cosa succede quando ignoriamo le
periferie i suoi problemi e le
conseguenze che questo a sulle persone e
sulla loro salute
ecco in realtà quando sono partito con
medici senza frontiere il primo posto
dove mi hanno mandato in italia nel sud
italia nelle periferie degradate del sud
nei luoghi e nei campi di lavoro
ecco questo è stato circa 20 anni fa
agli albori del fenomeno migratorio
ecco e qui ho prestato la mia opera come
medico e sono avevo passato dei mesi a
contatto con questi ragazzi che facevano
questa migrazione dalla sicilia alla
calabria alla puglia la campania e poi
tornava indietro ho vissuto con loro li
ho curati e la cosa che diceva stata
un'esperienza molto scioccante quasi
drammatica per me non pensavo che in
italia ci fossero delle situazioni di
questo tipo le situazioni di lavoro e di
vita di queste persone le abbiamo
paragonate a quelle dei campi rifugiati
in africa
ok ci sembravano peggiori di quelle dei
campi rifugiati e anche le condizioni di
salute quelli che mi trovava a curare
erano molto spesso condizione che erano
dovute allo sfruttamento della persona e
lo sfruttamento del lavoro questo era 20
anni fa e da lì nacque una prima un
documento di inchiesta che facendo che
si chiamava i frutti dell'ipocrisia
ecco queste erano le condizioni in cui
trovavamo poi le persone e al tempo e ci
scandalizzò molto poi dopo il problema è
evoluto nel tempo e l'abbiamo visto
anche sui media nelle televisioni che
cosa è successo a non continuare
ignorare questo tipo di problemi ecco
dalle periferie del sud italia poi dopo
sono passato mi sono le periferie
dell'africa sono partito per l'etiopia
in gambella gambella una regione ovest
all'estremo ovest dell'etiopia e ai
confini
stato etiope e geograficamente fa parte
di quello che è il sud sudan
quindi tutto il bacino del nilo sia come
territorio che come popolazione eccola
gambella ha una storia molto particolare
ai tempi del regime quello dei dead
quello precedente ecco ci informano
tentativi di far insediare a queste
popolazioni nomadi che vivevano nel
nella gambella e organizzarle a forza e
allo stesso tempo le persone che
vivevano negli altri pani furono forza
costretti a migrare e andare a occupare
le basse terre e della gambella e quindi
a cambiare completamente il loro il loro
ambiente è inclusa anche la malattia e
poi venne risposto su negli altipiani
non c'è la malaria mentre in gambella è
una delle principali cause di morte ecco
una cosa interessante del gambella più o
meno vivono 250 mila abitanti in gran
bella e oggi ad oggi gambella ospita 400
mila profughi del sud sudan che
continuano ad arrivare è una crisi
silenziosa dimenticata anche questa è
ecco e quindi anche il panorama urbano
del della gam belle cambiato una volta
c'erano questi insediamenti queste case
queste capanne molto caratteristiche di
fango e paglia e adesso sono tutte
circondate da queste tendopoli più o
meno organizzate e questo ha portato
ovviamente un'enorme crisi è dovuta al
diciamo alla pressione demografica in un
posto relativamente piccolo con così
tante persone
e qui la malnutrizione è un uno dei
problemi più importanti da noi si parla
tanto di problemi di obesità infantile
invece esistono comunque ancora posti
dove la malnutrizione fa morire le
persone
ecco e anche qui in una delle risposte
che avevano dati come medici senza
frontiere e la riabilitazione della
malnutrizione su base comunitaria sono
poi le persone di queste periferie che
trovano poi delle soluzioni
ovviamente con la tecnologia con il
nostro supporto con
con un certo tipo di organizzazione
ecco dal dall etiopia sono passate
invece in sudafrica
questo per continuare insomma il mio
viaggio quello che è stato il mio
viaggio in questi anni
ecco questa è la township dica e licia è
una township ancora dai tempi
dell'apartheid dove oggi vivono circa
500.000 persone pensate che solo
recentemente è stato costruito un
ospedale in questa township ed ha avuta
anche questo è un'organizzazione molto
molto precaria e ovviamente molto
caotica ogni giorno vedete nuove
baracche che si aggiungono alle baracche
precedente questa è una migrazione
invece che avviene all'interno del del
paese sudafrica se la gente daily star
che implant ormonale povere del sud
africa che a ondate arriva nella ricca
città del capo e questo ha fatto diciamo
crescere queste baraccopoli a dismisura
e con queste a partire dagli a 990
quelli che sono stati grandi problemi di
questo paese
la hiv aids ricordiamo c'è un paese
ancora dove un adulto su cinque a malata
di hiv aids
le violenze sulle donne una donna su
quattro
racconta di aver violino di aver subito
almeno una violenza sessuale nel corso
della propria vita e la tubercolosi
ovviamente anche questo se la pensiamo
dal punto di vista urbanistica tutte
queste casette piccole e sovraffollate
dove basta su un malato di tubercolosi
per poi fare diciamo prendere fuoco
all'epidemia e avere un numero altissimo
di casi
questo succedeva in un paese che ai
tempi parlano i primi anni 2000 aveva un
presidente della repubblica thabo mbeki
che era un negazionista della che diceva
allah che la tv si cura con l'aglio e la
barbabietola ok e la comunità
scientifica occidentale ma molto
scettica portare in medicina per la cai
v in africa non è possibile invece noi
abbiamo avuto il coraggio di farlo
questo abbia avuto il coraggio
supportati anche da persone che ci hanno
detto che eravamo sulla strada giusta
nel suo piccolo mundell è venuto s'è
messo la maglietta di hev positivo
dedicarci che sì eravamo nella direzione
giusta anche se avevamo tutto
l'establishment contro e li abbiamo
cercato di fare di tutto abbiamo aperto
cliniche supportato ospedali abbiamo
distribuito farmaci anche lì in un
sistema sanitario fragile con milioni di
pazienti che hanno bisogno di accesso
alle cure anche lì la soluzione è
arrivata dalla gente dalle persone
stesse e quindi questi gruppi di auto
aiuto persone che si mettevano a piccoli
gruppi 56 persone e un sistema di
delegazione per andare a recuperare
medicina accendo che salute quindi oggi
vado io domani vai tu domani va l'altro
questo non solo riduceva diciamo il peso
sul sistema sanitario ma anche creava
diciamo dei piccoli gruppi di pazienti
che diventava la loro forza della
comunità anche a combattere quello che
era lo stigma che in quel periodo era
molto forte
ecco questo è stata l'esperienza del
sudafrica dopo il sudafrica
io nel mio piccolo provato ma ecco
diciamo diciamo ha cercato di comunque
seguire questo percorso
ecco e dal sudafrica poi dove se
passiamo alla liberia le bola
ecco le bolle è stata la cosa più
drammatica che abbia mai assistito è
stata una cosa guardate che veramente
dell'incredibile avrei mille storie che
purtroppo per questioni di tempo non
riesco a raccontarvi però quello che
volevo dire delle bola che anche le boe
la alla fine e nasce in un luogo di
quest'epidemia è nata in un luogo di
periferia è in un confine una frontiera
e la frontiera tra guinea guinea sierra
leone liberia
non a caso un'area di forte sfruttamento
delle risorse che ci sono deforestazione
per l'industria del legname e
sfruttamento minerario e non è un caso
che sia proprio avvenuto il passaggio
del virus dagli animali all'uomo perché
quando tu distruggere l'ambiente in cui
questi animali vivono
poi dopo il contatto tra animali un uomo
è molto più facile e lì c'è stato il
passaggio della malattia dal virus per
del virus dall'animale all'uomo e poi
dopo il contagio la trasmissione è stato
tra uomini quelle quelle strade che noi
avevamo aperto per portarci via le
risorse hanno portato alla malattia ai
centri abitati alle grandi città e
questo io mi trovavo sono arrivata a
monrovia una settimana prima che
l'epidemia esplodesse nella città una
città di più di due milioni di abitanti
è che questo questo e west point una
delle zone più degradate di morobe una
penisola con un accesso molto stretto a
resto della città e all'inizio ed è un
poi è stato il ritrovo per anni dopo la
guerra civile di persone che dei
desideri da at dei poveri dei criminali
e si pensava che l'epidemia fosse
venisse da lì e allora la prima risposta
del governo che è stata diciamo
abbastanza interessante è stato quello
di mettere dei fili spinati di bloccare
l'accesso a quel quartiere nessuno
poteva più uscire nessuno poteva più
entrare erano convinti che avrebbero
fermato l'epidemia e non si sono resi
conto che in realtà l'epidemia era già
in tutta la città era già era già tutta
colpita morobbia quando hanno preso
queste misure eccoli abbiamo fatto delle
cose incredibili direi abbiamo costruito
dei centri di trattamento ebola enormi
ecco una situazione in cui i pazienti
arrivavano a decine ogni giorno ea volte
bisognava chiudere i cancelli perché non
sapevamo dove metterli le persone ci
morivano davanti prima che potessimo
curarle abbiamo distribuito a un certo
punto kit igienici in tutta la città per
provare a ridurre il contagio diminuire
il contagio tra le persone questo
prendendo dei rischi enormi
ecco e ecco finché le epidemie stava in
questi paesi la comunità internazionale
non ha mosso un dito solo con iniziata a
ri vari casi in occidente
allora abbiamo deciso hanno deciso di
muoversi ma la prima risposta è stata
anche quello di mettere delle barriere
è di intensificare i controlli evitare
che l'epidemia arrivasse da noi qui
questo è stato diciamo il primo passo
solo dopo credo colpevolmente si sono
resi conto che solo dopo si sono accorti
che in realtà in questi paesi c'erano
migliaia di persone che erano già state
infettate
molti dei quali erano già morte e non è
solo questo e anche milioni di persone
in realtà lasciati senza un'assistenza
sanitaria perché ricordiamoci che le boe
la colpisce ha colpito soprattutto i
medici e gli infermieri quelli che i
primi che si prendeva la cura dei malati
e questo ha portato un collasso diciamo
delle strutture sanitarie in tutti
questi paesi
dopo le boe la un grande respiro
un'altra e un'altra piede mia
il colera anche qui siamo in a periferia
del mondo siamo in mozambico
anche qui un'area di forte sfruttamento
delle risorse miniere scoperte da poco
quindi urbanizzazione e rapida anche qui
baraccopoli che nascono e crescono a
dismisura senza senza strutture
igieniche sempre accesso all'acqua e
pensate qui siamo a tete in mozambico 3
epidemie di colera in due anni
e il governo che ovviamente più attenta
all'immagine del paese e agli
investitori e ad attrarre investitori
che arrivino in questi paesi
ecco negavano non c'è nessuna epidemia
non c'è niente qui la rabbia la
frustrazione
eravamo lì potevamo salvarla quelle
persone ma no il colera non esiste
nonostante che ci fossero situazioni di
questo tipo
ecco e qui la frustrazione appunto di
non potere fare nulla nonostante che i
problemi fossero davanti ai nostri occhi
ecco periferie negate ecco dopo questo
percorso che è durato dieci anni sono
tornati in italia l'anno scorso
ecco quelle baracche che aveva trovato
nel sud dell'italia
adesso sono grandi insediamenti
informali come questo
di borgo mezzanone sembrano quasi delle
città che sono cresciute a dismisura
mentre io ero dall'altra parte del mondo
ecco che ci troviamo dentro dentro a
questi posti programmi e richiede intesi
le rifugiate tende che ci sta legalmente
qua che abbiamo il dovere di aiutare ed
assistere che in qualche modo però è
stata espulsa o non è mai entrata in
quello che sono i circuiti di
accoglienza ecco i problemi sono gli
stessi che denunciamo 15 anni fa manca
la luce manca l'acqua mancano l'accesso
alle cure per queste persone e nessuno
che muove un dito e questi sono diritti
negati guardate non è solo una questione
degli immigrati anche nelle nostre
periferie anche gli italiani saranno le
hanno gli stessi problemi
ecco e quindi abbiamo i diritti negati
ai più vulnerabili
da una parte dall'altra chi cerca di
aiutare colpevolizzato ok e distribuire
cibo aiutare una persona da un passaggio
a qualcuno ecco questo oggi ti può
portare a essere criminalizzato e anche
arrestato salvare qualcuno che che sta
annegando anche questo sta diventando un
crimine
una volta quando ero via ci chiamavano
angeliche salvavamo le persone
adesso ci chiamano criminali tassisti
del mare trafficanti c'è cuore reati
stiamo minando quelle che sono le basi
secondo me che sono i fondamenti di
quello che sta alla base della nostra
società il principio della solidarietà
allora per cercare un po di combattere
questo io credo che possiamo fare tutti
ognuno di noi con le proprie competenze
possiamo fare qualcosa
ok e medici senza frontiere ha lanciato
questa questa campagna umani che vuole
torre da importare un po all'essenza del
gesto umanitario gesto umanitario che
possiamo fare fare chiunque di noi
anzi vi direi che è molto salutare farlo
quasi a farlo tutti i giorni ecco ecco
equa abbiamo messo al centro queste
cinque mozioni che accomunano sia noi
operatori umanitari che i nostri
pazienti in tutte le parti del mondo
ecco io credo che che ognuno di noi può
fare tanto importante ecco a ricordarci
di esseri umani
di dolore quando mancano le cure di
rabbia quando ci sembra ingiusto di
gioia quando ce la facciamo
di paura quando pensiamo di non farcela
di speranza sempre
di carne e ossa ecco di cosa siamo fatti
noi umani sosteniamoci medici senza
frontiere punto it
[Applauso]